let me let me tell you about our two we
got the story from timcast.com staff of
rt america laid off as network announces
it is halting production in a memo to
its employees rt america cited
unforeseen business interruption events
yeah it could be war well but um
let me tell you about uh
russia today in sputnik i was at the rt
and sputnik offices in 2016 in 2016
during the election with cassandra
fairbanks
and the people in that office
every single one saved cassandra was a
pro-democrat pro-hillary activist or
individual
they were crying when donald trump
started winning and then when he won
people were crying how many rubles were
you paid to say that tim zero rubles all
of the rubles we all we know we know
from the dossier that the ukrainians had
nothing to do with no no
that russia wanted trump to win we know
this well you you look at the content
that rt has promoted the people they've
hired they're anti-war
anti-establishment and typically
leftists like during occupy wall street
people are like oh yeah rt like i knew a
ton of people who during occupied occupy
would be like you got to watch rt
because they were the ones telling the
truth about occupy wall street or
another way to put it is promoting
anti-establishment protests united
states that could potentially
destabilize i thought rt and al jazeera
were great sources during the syrian con
when they wanted to go and invade syria
i was like what's really going on and
people it was like people like uh like
lee camp people like lee camp speaking
out against the syrian war on rt i don't
know if he was on his rt show at that
point if he had started redacted at
night at that point or on his first show
lee kemp he's uh anti-war i've known him
for a long time i always
thought of him as more of a lefty guy
redacted tonight was a show in rt has
rejected tonight has been cancelled
because the u.s war machine can't handle
the truth if you want to follow my work
go to leadcamp.com but not only that his
show on spotify
so let me see he retweeted it a while
ago it's probably on mine i don't know
if uh twitter's gonna let me pull it up
because i make me log in so here we go
his his podcast on spotify has been
taken down as well which is insane
because i don't think it had anything to
do with uh oh come on you're gonna load
or not twitter's so stupid let me see if
i can pull it up again i don't think his
show had anything to do with uh
there we go with russia today he says a
great deal of anti-war and leftist shows
are currently being deleted by spotify
including my personal podcast moment of
clarity you can continue to get all of
my stuff by signing up for my email list
at leecamp.com
and uh radindymedia.com my question is
if that's just lee camp's personal
podcast which he also has on youtube
moment of clarity he's got 18 000
subscribers
why did he get banned from spotify
irrational fear porn russian fear he was
hired by rt he's an american citizen rt
america i mean uh yeah technically rt i
guess yeah he's paying his bills but
that doesn't mean they're telling him
what to say look at this
rachel blevins who does not work for rt
anymore because rt doesn't exist is
labeled russian state affiliated media
on twitter she's never going to be able
to get rid of that none of these people
are
yo i hope they do i mean oh this is
something i want to talk about imagine
noise with how long after you commit a
crime or some sort of transgression do
you have to bear the title of that just
think about what this means moving
forward the hysteria when they are
labeling people with as russians
what happens if this war escalates you
think internment camps are the question
you would be no of course not especially
if as you said food's going to get a lot
more expensive and the establishment
isn't going to say that it has anything
to do with their irresponsibility in
printing trillions of dollars into
basing our currency it's because of what
the russians are doing in ukraine blame
them it's their fault and your russian
next door neighbor if you happen to have
one is just as culpable as anybody else
or more culpable than uh than we are
certainly and so no it's it's not out of
the question when food gets expensive
and you have to decide who gets it then
the prisoners are not the ones
they're going to scapegoat some i'm not
saying it's necessarily going to be the
russians but they're going to scapegoat
somebody
it's already started yeah it's it's
clearly already started they're being
scapegoated they're being skateboarded
for the inflation they're and not just
ever like if you're from russia if
you're from belarus right and i've i've
talked to belarusians right i've heard
from russians about this i heard you're
sleeping with belarusian oh yeah
that's one way to put it uh they hate
this
they hate this war but you have to
understand they are underneath their
regimes right these are not democracies
you can't actually judge this the exact
same way that you would somewhere else
right um and i don't remember the united
states getting completely canceled every
american canceled because of the iraq
war the iraq invasion which was by the
way yes unilateral invasion obviously
that doesn't justify uh the aggression
that putin's doing right now but at the
same time you have to look at this and
say look these people are subjects of
their regimes their subjects
authoritarian leaders like lukashenko
like putin they don't have any way to
effectively respond yeah they can
protest and then they all get arrested
just like up in you know canada um you
know another bastion democracy up there
and so you're going to turn around and
yet blame all of the people who just
want to live their lives who literally
just want to live their lives and don't
want to be involved in this i don't
think that our invasion of iraq and
libya are our current inva that we are
doing right now we're invading those
countries today right now uh i don't
think it justifies the invasion but it
definitely explains it
well it destroys our moral standing in
the world and so how can you turn around
from a governmental perspective and say
well we disagree with you doing that
when you look at what the united states
by the way yes through nato has done
throughout the years right and so when
you look at libya when you look
afghanistan when you look at iraq you
just go around you could literally walk
place to place to place it's nothing but
death and destruction other than you
know the protection of some parts of
europe
why is someone yelling yeah what's up
dude
i watched oh this is this is the live
stream okay this is uh that's the live
stream oh no no the next video yeah it's
the next video
i watched a video on uday hussein last
night because rogan i heard him mention
he was talking to majid nawaz on his
show about how horrible saddam's kids
were and i was like oh yeah so uday
hussein it looks like he was just like
daddy's little boy who saddam beat the
hell out of growing up and then
daddy was like you can have anything you
want son anything every video you find
of uday he's tripping his balls off it's
like he just takes psychedelics it's
like he's in it dude and he just
beat that
okay yeah this is a little off topic but
america went in saying we got to stop
human atrocity and uday was
putting people in like bleeding machines
he was a psychopath so but still the
invasion is completely irrational let me
pull the street from kyle griffin kyle
griffin of course what is he uh uh msnbc
producer
says the national association of
broadcasters has issued a statement
calling on broadcasters to stop carrying
russian-sponsored programming that's
affiliated with the russian government
or its agents and what are the responses
what do you think people are saying
whatever is it who are it saying
foxes off the air does that include fox
no good for fox right so who right so
who gets labeled a russian agent now
because i remember in
the mueller investigation during all of
russiagate everyone was labeled a
russian agent everyone yeah so this is
my prediction they're going to start
calling all russians bad and then
they're going to start calling all
republicans russians well they've been
doing that for seven years
i
i think national association of
broadcasters the ceo of that is still
biden's best friend chris dodd i'm
pretty sure i have to look at that i
think i thought senator dodd was the
head of the nab which would be
interesting i mean every every trade
association has a former senator
remember the dodd sam remember the dodd
kennedy sandwich exactly that same crist
that that chris died it's interesting um
the way i mean we've said this before
the left constantly projects and so
that's part of why they're always
accusing everyone else of being racist
they are extremely obsessed with race
and ethnic identity that's why they say
things like even if a person isn't white
when they're doing something that favors
the system or the patriarchy they are
acting as a white supremacist they're
acting in the stead of whiteness and now
with all this going on of course it's
all russians even ones who have
absolutely nothing to do with the
conflict even though most of them living
in the country had absolutely no ability
to make any decision whether or not
ukraine was going to be invaded yeah
exactly they're they're all being
slapped with this label
and in the same way
in the same way that you often see
black political commentators who happen
to be conservative labeled as white or
white supremacists i agree with with uh
lydia that we're going to see people
being labeled as russian or russian
agencies you know uh i now now or at the
very least that that's very important
you've got to look back at
history to see
what will happen now that we can
consider to be a rhyme history doesn't
repeat it crimes so um
what could happen now well freezing of
bank accounts already seen it yep yep
suspension of of uh accounts through
through other uh like like airbnb and
things like that other services
being totally removed from social media
they have put a label on rachel blevins
this is creepy stuff maybe they'll
change russian state affiliated media
she doesn't work there anymore twitter
should remove it immediately
lee camp having his personal podcast
deleted
for simply having worked for rt in a
separate capacity it was completely
deleted off on spotify spotify motion
does he have cop backups oh it's on
youtube as well youtube hasn't taken it
down but this is this is where it starts
getting really creepy uh creepy
where they're basically gonna start
labeling people as like
lessers
or um it's like the others
they're gonna say are you an other was
that a black mirror episode what was
that movie or what that tv show remember
remember i don't know if you guys
remember that one where people are like
are you an other i think it was movie i
think yeah it was a movie yeah where
some guy is like
you know here's on tv a politician say
something about i don't want to repeat
it because youtube
i know what you're taught i think um i
think i passed in and out of the room as
you guys were watching this yeah it
wasn't black mirror but it was a similar
anthology yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah what
was it creep show maybe or something i
don't know i don't know but it's like
the tv on a politician says something
about like all others are bad it's like
some new tv and literally says very on
the nose channel is it channel uh zero
maybe i don't know i watch a bunch of
these weird sci-fi things and then he
goes around and he's like what was that
the other day when they're talking about
the others and they're like why do you
care are you another he goes no no i
just saw that and like what is that
about and they were like you're not
defending others are you and he was like
no no i just don't understand and then
eventually the more he started asking
questions about why you're demonizing
others they said you must be an other
and he sees like a woman running on the
street screaming help and they're just
beating the crap out of her and he's
like why are you doing that and they're
like she's an other and he's like well
stop hitting her i'm like you must be an
other two yeah that's where we're going
russians
they're gonna ban you they're gonna shut
you down they're gonna put a label on
you let me correct myself cristada's
motion picture association ah oh
they're gonna make sure make it clear
they are going to make you wear
a tag on your social media profiles
identifying you as
russian state-affiliated media and 30
years ago seinfeld did that skit with
the age ribbon who would wear the ribbon
right right hey i'm marched i'm marched
who does not want to wear the ribbon
that's where we are now so we were at
the at the um
the state of the union and it's and by
the way you know i look at that stuff
and i saw there was like a photo op that
they did with this like american
ukrainian flag thing i hate whatever
today i hate that so you're defacing our
flag that by the way that is a
defacement that's actually the you have
changed the face of the flag that's
where the word defacement comes from uh
of the flag itself um in order to do
that so you're not actually going to do
anything for the people of ukraine you
you sold them all this all these weapons
and you provoked russia you talked about
them joining nato so you lied to them
about that and you sold them as false
promise now that russia is pissed off
they're attacking you um they've gone
completely insane so they're shelling
cities at this point they're using
artillery on cities and russia's not
going to stop because this is about how
russia fights um and in the meanwhile
instead of you know actually helping the
ukrainian people that you promised
you're not going to do that but you're
going to hold photo ops and you're going
to put on lapel pins and put up hashtags
as if that's actually going to stop
anyone from dying the the show was
electric dreams thank you for waffle
sensing
yeah electric james awesome show by the
way that episode
seriously i talked about before you guys
should watch
it's the last episode it's an anthology
series
i thought it was absolutely fantastic uh
can i ask the authorization of people
yeah that's really well can i ask
something here um does does twitter do
this with people who are affiliated with
state media generally speaking or are
they only doing this to people
affiliated with russian state media i
think they do with chinese state media
okay but do they do it to the bbc no or
the cbs indian state media that's a
great point there's a lot of indian
state and npr
yeah well i i think what does npr get
like a microscopic force yeah or
al-jazeera's small percent
all of al jazeera is owned by the qatari
government yeah yeah yeah
al jazeera plus all the rest well you
know the amazing thing was about the
demonization of russia today which
always confused me was that al jazeera
plus
pushed the exact same opinions as rt for
the most part for the most part yeah and
it was funded by by the qatari
government yet it was never demonized
and i was confused by this it was clear
the issue was the nation of russia and
not the propaganda of you know it's not
the messaging of what they're doing it's
the fact that russia owns it so if
another channel is state-owned and does
literally the same thing promoting the
exact same things
of course i just find it very
interesting that the elite and the
ruling class have absolutely no problem
with information being imported into our
country that's going to destabilize our
unity as a country it just bothers them
on the basis of who's doing it yo
they're so yeah because they're the only
ones who want to be able to do exactly
exactly useful to them i want to see joe
biden come out and say president
zielinski
you have our support
but you must condemn the azov battalion
we will not tolerate neo-nazism
i want to see him stand by his campaign
message about white nationalism and
white supremacy and offer up his support
to zelensky and ukraine but in but
condemn the neo-nazis of the azerbaijani
the entire reason joe biden decided to
run for president was charlottesville
that's right he's literally been on the
record saying that that's the entire
reason he decided to run for president
so why isn't he saying something about
this yeah as of the time weird no joke
uh imagine noise on the show last night
was really trying to hammer this one
home this is so what's happening is
people from around the world are going
to ukraine to fight with the azov and
then they're getting radicalized and
then when this is done what he sees
happening or what he fears is that
they're going to go back home
for newly radicalized and with all this
military training now and then spread
this nazism around the world it's it's
the mujahideen all over again it's it's
going to be like the syrian rebels to
isis you're going to have these people
go there be radicalized fight for an
ideology and then maintain that or
you're going to empower people of
radical ideology with military training
and capabilities and we know where that
goes but i tell you this man
history rhymes the us continually does
this and it's almost like they like
doing it it's good for whatever it is i
shouldn't even say the us the west
halliburton yeah the military industrial
complex for sure well and we know how it
works anyone who can be even
tangentially associated with the right
is uh a person who we can blame the
entirety of the conservative movement
for every single thing that they do so
they're constantly conflating regular
conservatives with the far right with
nazis etc and so if there are these
attacks if majid's prediction comes true
and i think it's a very interesting and
compelling one then what's going to
happen is you will have neo-nazis
engaging in violence more often because
they'll have acquired combat experience
and then what's going to happen is
they're going to say look at the rise in
far-right violence now we need to censor
regular run-of-the-mill conservatives
because it was them who radicalized
people by pushing them down these rabbit
holes which turned them into nazis it's
also an excuse to ramp up federal
military police mm-hmm when you have
internal strife like nazism yesterday
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm we'll see you all there